joining us now president Trump's
attorney Rudy Giuliani mr. mayor I'll
dismiss rosy is being the extremist she
is but you know here you are here's the
president having a great time saying
goodbye to somebody a kiss on the cheek
you slow it down it's still a kiss on
the cheek I'll rewrap it and show it and
this is this is every second every
minute every hour of every day attack
the president yeah I know and and lucky
we have the the the footage because you
know some people would just believe it
and I think it's because the media a lot
of the media has created this hysteria
about about about the president I mean
the whole Muller investigation was
infused with that it's investigation
never should have happened they printed
the wildest craziest lives and of course
they have never apologized for it so I
think people feel empowered to say
anything they want I mean something like
that should have serious sanctions so it
doesn't happen again
you know mr. mayor I know you're an
Albanian tonight and I know you're there
for a particular reason which is a
hundred years of freedom but with the
Iranian resistance but here's what I
want to ask you so we know where the
economy stands obama-biden versus
presidents from best employment
situation since 1969
records for every demographic group but
on the issue look at everybody's foreign
policy positions especially Biden one
hundred and fifty billion dollars on the
tarmac in cash and other currencies for
the Mo's of Iran I'm having a hard time
ever understanding bribing dictators
that say say in chant death to America
well you know one of the problems here I
mean people died as a result of it was
Obama sent Biden to negotiate the Status
of Forces Agreement in Iraq of course as
he did every time he dealt with foreign
policy he failed miserably we pulled all
our troops out and 120 of these people
were killed by the Iranians and it took
Herculean efforts by this organization
me will we free mike bkz a number of
others to get these people finally
brought to albania so we could fulfill
the promise we made to them to protect
them they were abandoned by Obama
abandoned by Biden and they are our ally
this is the epicenter of the Iranian
resistance where I'm sitting right now
they broadcast 24 hours a day into Iran
like they're The Voice of America they
were shunned by the Obama administration
the Obama administration went so far
that some of these people were killed
and luckily with this administration he
supports the resistance movement the
President does and the administration
does and the killing has stopped and a
lot of protests are going on inside of
Iran and this is a great alternative to
that horrible regime in Iran we could
overturn that regime be better for the
entire world
they foment terror they fight proxy wars
and they have a 150 billion extra
dollars because of Biden Obama mr. mayor
enjoy your conference thank you for
being with us we appreciate